if you happen to stumble upon any of the
numerous predator films without seeing
all the ones that came before you might
come away confused here's what each
entry in the predator series means in
the context of the franchise including
what it adds to the bigger picture
mythos
predator follows an elite team of
mercenaries on a rescue mission deep in
the heart of a guerrilla controlled area
in central america the team led by
ex-special forces major allen dutch
schaefer quickly finds unexpected
helicopter wreckage a slew of skinned
corpses and evidence of a killer that
leaves no tracks they make quick work of
a group of insurgents taking one unarmed
female insurgent anna captive as the
mercenary team moves forward the unseen
foe starts to pick off members one by
one you ain't afraid of no man
there's something out there waiting for
us
and it ain't no man
anna tells dutch of a local legend a
creature that hunts humans for sport
eventually only dutch and anna remain
and dutch realizes the creature only
targets armed prey he sends anna off
alone so she'll be safe from its attacks
dutch becomes covered in mud discovering
that the mud allows him to hide from the
entity as it moves on dutch is able to
damage its cloaking device but he is
still overcome by the creature aka the
predator more accurately known as a
yacht jaw it drops his armor and weapons
for a fair fight and dutch nearly loses
before catching the predator in a trap
the fallen yacht draw activates a
self-destruct device dutch narrowly
escapes fleeing just before the
creature's self-destruction
as our introduction to the species
predator demonstrates a number of
characteristics of the creature visually
they're adorned in seemingly light but
powerful armor and have menacingly tough
alien bodies they have a high technology
space-faring civilization with an
advanced and distinct language deadly
weapons cloaking technology and they're
smart
strong adaptive warriors who can spot
and create traps the yacht draw or hair
killing arm pray for sport often hunt
alone skin their quarry and take
trophies if their hunt fails and they're
facing death they'd rather kill
themselves than lose at this point in
the franchise we can only infer that
such a hunt was the predator's sole
motivation for traveling to earth
from the film we learned that the yacht
jaw actually enjoyed the challenge and
also exhibit a menacing joy in getting
that last one-up kill on their prey the
film effectively set the tone for every
subsequent portrayal of the entity and
its legacy affects the series the film
received mixed critical reviews in its
day but its box office success was
undeniable netting 98 million dollars on
a production budget of 18 million the
film cemented the predators as an iconic
movie monster species fueling 20th
century fox to green light numerous
direct and spin-off sequels over
subsequent decades
the second film shifts the action into
urban territory a gang war brings the
involvement of lapd lieutenant mike
harrigan and his team the cops barge
into a hideout to find a colombian gang
slaughter and harrigan follows the panic
survivor to the roof to see the vague
transparent silhouette of a large
semi-invisible man at his precinct
harrigan is introduced to special agent
keys the leader of a task force
investigating the cartels that night
another gangland killing is interrupted
by the predator harrigan and his team
investigate the scene of the crime and
find an alien spear keys enters and
threatens harrigan to stay away but
harrigan returns and pursues the
predator he's captured by keys team who
explains that the predator is a
camouflaged alien hunter who prowls
areas with armed conflict drawn by heat
and conflict he's on safari
lions
the tigers the bears
oh my
trophies
keys team sets a trap but they are
easily overcome by the yacht jaw and
harrigan pursues the alien himself the
fight between the predator and harrigan
continues downward into tunnels beneath
the city where harrigan discovers the
yacht-jaw spacecraft and its
skull-adorned trophy room which happens
to include a skull that looks like it
belongs to a xenomorph from the alien
franchise he manages to kill the yacht
jaw with its own weapon causing a group
of predators to appear collect the
fallen alien and present harrigan with a
trophy
predator 2 made a number of important
leaps for our understanding of the
mythos of the predators first it widened
the scope of the types of warrior combat
and prey we know predators hunt and show
that there is willing to hunt in crowded
city centers as they are in remote
combat zones while the film added new
weapons to their arsenal it also shows
that lone hunter yacht jaw don't travel
to a planet unobserved other hunters
will take the body of a fallen comrade
home upon its failure to self-destruct a
unique evolution of their culture that
adds significant ritual to their hunts
the film also explains the species
propensity to travel to this planet to
hunt humans for sport particularly in
combat zones and that at least some
groups in the government are aware of
the predation finally in showing the
ship's trophy room and the xenomorph
skull within it it suggests that the
alien and predator worlds take place in
the same universe and that the yacht jar
hunt xenomorphs ii the first cinematic
introduction of that concept
predator 2 added to the yacht jaws
weaponry and tactical powers implicitly
provided the intellectual underpinning
for the alien vs predator spin-off films
and evolved our yacht-jaw cultural
understanding showing their entire alien
civilization is built around the hut
despite the film's current cult classic
status predator 2 suffered mostly
negative reviews in its day and fared
much more poorly at the box office than
its predecessor the film's relatively
lackluster performance at the time
effectively paused the franchise until
the alien vs predator spinoff franchise
hit in 2004. in short predator 2 proved
mighty influential in its cementing many
aspects of predator lore but its
relative lack of success paused the
individual franchise for some time
in 2004's alien vs predator wealthy
industrialist charles bishop whalen
assembles a teen to investigate a
mysterious heat signature beneath an
island north of antarctica meanwhile a
predator ship reaches earth's orbit and
fires an energy beam straight at the
heat signature's location creating a
tunnel to its source an ancient pyramid
the team finds the tunnel as well as
evidence of ancient humans in what
seemed to be sacrificial chambers the
team unintentionally activates devices
within the pyramid reanimating a
xenomorph queen from stasis who produces
a host of xenomorph eggs face huggers
attach to humans trapped in the
sacrificial chamber quickly maturing
into adult xenomorphs conflict erupts
and escalates between the xenomorphs
humans and the yacht-jaw and one of the
yajja known as scar finds himself
attacked by a facehugger
hieroglyph translations reveal that
predators have been visiting earth for
thousands of years and were once
worshipped as gods they periodically
return as part of a hunting ritual where
humans are sacrificed to produce
xenomorphs as prey weyland team guide
lex and scar form an alliance planting
scar's self-destruct device in the
xenomorph hive to destroy the remaining
xenomorphs and eggs the queen survives
but the pair ultimately defeat her
although scar dies from wounds received
in battle a predator ship uncloaks and
the yachtjaw present lex with a spear
then takes scar's body before ascending
the film ends as we watch a pred alien a
combination of predators and aliens
burst from his chest alien vs predator
is notably the first film to establish
that the predators have been hunting on
earth for thousands of years and more
than that they were instrumental in the
earliest human civilizations and were a
major factor in the development of early
human culture and possibly religion we
also find out earth is at least one
special location where yacht jaw rites
of passage were conducted to facilitate
the xenomorph hunt
long treated as non-canon the two film
alien vs predator series introduces a
variety of aspects to both predator and
alien mythos while predator 2 suggested
the two species share the same universe
it took a detail in 2018's the predator
to subtly reinforce it in that movie kc
bracket is shown the alien tail combi
spear crafted for lex and avp implicitly
confirming their canonicity in the
official predator universe though given
ridley scott's antipathy towards the
crossover and the prometheus and alien
covenant detailed differences it's safe
to say they're not canon in the alien
franchise additionally despite its
critical detractors the film performed
quite well at the box office with 172
million dollars worldwide on a 70
million dollar budget breathing new life
into the predator and alien franchises
that said its influence is nonetheless
still controversial for predator
purposes we can safely say that the
current state of the franchise validates
its additions to predator lore
avp requiem begins exactly where avp
left off with a hatched predelion
emerging from scar's fallen body
rampaging through the craft and crashing
it outside a colorado town the ship's
distress signal is received by the elite
predator wolf who travels to earth to
eradicate the pred alien and any face
huggers that escaped on earth a number
of facehuggers find hosts while wolfe
lands and starts to clean up evidence of
the alien menace wolf tracks a number of
xenomorphs into the town sewers and
several escape into the town above
meanwhile several humans regroup at a
local sporting goods store wolf and
xenomorphs enter and battle inside the
store as their surviving humans escape
the survivors contact the military and
are directed to the center of town for
evacuation the human survivors split off
with some moving to use the hospital's
helicopter to escape the area the
hospital splinter group finds the
building overrun by xenomorphs and the
predalien and wolf arrives to kill a
number of the xenos losing a blaster in
the process the humans grab the blaster
and conflict rages between them the
xenomorphs and wolf the human survivors
fight their way to the roof board the
chopper and take off all while wolf and
the pred alien engage in final combat on
the roof mortally wounding each other
meanwhile the military has lied about
the evacuation and instead bombs the
city to eliminate the alien threat the
shockwave crashes the escaping hospital
helicopter where the remaining survivors
are rescued by awaiting military forces
soon wolf's recovered plasma blaster is
presented to a woman named mrs yutani
building directly off its predecessor
alien vs predator requiem shows that
predators will call on the assistance of
others in case of emergency and that the
species will sometimes attempt to clean
up evidence of their activities
additionally they seem intent on
preventing xenomorphs from escaping to
dominate a planet we also see wolf used
weapons that we have not seen in use by
other yacht jaw including the yacht jaw
whip laser mines and the power punch
glove that amplifies the predator's
punching power finally we see an
extraterrestrial plasma pistol given to
ms yutani of the yutani corporation the
company's 2099 merger with the weyland
corp produced the weyland-yutani
corporation we see in the alien films
like avp whether or not requiem's
contributions are cannon hinges entirely
on the overall status of the spin-offs
the film was overall received more
poorly than any other predator film yet
it earned a higher profit margin than
the preceding spin-off at a 128 million
dollar take on a 40 million dollar
budget the near universally poor
critical reception put the director's
plans for a third spin-off on indefinite
hold nonetheless its contributions to
yacht draw weaponry and culture have
stayed with the franchise
[Music]
predators begins with mercenary royce
waking up while parachuting into an
unfamiliar jungle alongside several
other humans as it turns out they're all
armed and lethal killers except for one
a doctor named edwin when night comes
they see an alien sky for the first time
realizing they're no longer on earth the
makeshift teammates soon find themselves
attacked by four-legged extraterrestrial
beasts before a whistle calls them off
the team discovers a captive predator
but are soon attacked by three massive
super predators known as the tracker
berserker and falconer the human team
flees and eventually encounter ronald
nolan a lone u.s soldier who survived on
the alien planet by looting and hiding
nolan reveals the planet is a predator
game reserve where yacht jaw trained
against deadly warriors and creatures
there the predators hunt in threes and
the smaller and larger yard jaw feud the
larger ones hunt the smaller ones
it's some kind of
blood feud i guess been going on for a
long time
conflict between the predators and the
humans eventually kills nolan several
team members and the tracker and
falconer yacha edwin becomes injured and
isabelle refuses to leave him but royce
moves on to free the captured yacht-jaw
in hope of escape the smaller yacht-jaw
activates a ship and programs its return
to earth the berserker arrives kills the
smaller yacht-jaw and blows up the ship
royce returns for the others and
discovers edwin has revealed himself to
have been a serial killer back on earth
knowing edwin's far more than an
innocent doctor royce uses him as a
grenade trapped bait the berserker
triggers the trap and royce and isabelle
kill it the film ends with the pair
looking at the alien sky as more
parachutes fall
predators adds a large array of elements
to the mythology of the predator
universe first and perhaps most notably
is that the predator species has two
distinct subspecies with a long history
of antagonism and a considerable size
difference the smaller group is often
referred to as the jungle hunter clan
while the super predators are larger and
more muscular we also learn that while
jungle hunter yaja frequently travel
across the galaxy to hunt various prey
super predator yaja have a planet of
unknown location where they regularly
deposit and hunt dangerous species this
is also the first instance in the film
series where yatra are seen hunting with
quadrupedal animals a facet of their
hunting culture that hasn't yet been
shown on screen finally there's the case
of edwin the yacht-jaw have long been
known to hunt armed combatants in combat
zones situations where predation is
easily visible for a predator to track
find in hunt arm prey with edwin we
discover that the predator's methods of
reconnaissance are much more
sophisticated as they were able to
discover that he was a killer despite
his methods being less visible than the
armed combatants that predators
typically hunt
with predators fox reinvigorated the
franchise reorienting it away from the
avp spin-offs and towards new individual
predator altics the film added a lot to
the mythos an entirely new race of yacht
jaw a game reserve planet a new level of
detail in the yacht jaws search for
deadly combatants and hunting animals
the film grossed 127 million dollars on
a 40 million dollar budget and received
the most acclaim in the film franchise
since the 1987 original super predators
have not appeared in a subsequent film
but the film's cinematic sequel the
predator does contain a massive predator
with genetically modified dna it's
unclear however if there is a connection
between the super predators and that
film's massive yacht jaw
the predator opens with one yacht jaw
ship fleeing another before crash
landing on earth interrupting army
ranger quinn mckenna's mission the alien
attacks his team before he incapacitates
it with its weaponry and flees with
yacht jaw armor mckenna manages to send
the technology home when he returns he's
interrogated by agents from project
stargazer and put on a military prison
transport biologist casey brackett
arrives at a stargazer research lab to
investigate the captured predator body
and the inexplicably spliced dna its
body contains the predator wakes up
rampages and flees mckenna and other
soldiers hijack their prison transport
meet up with bracket and proceed to
mckenna's house they discovered that
mckenna's autistic son rory had found
the yacht-jaw armor and left the house
actually wearing it mckenna and the
soldiers eventually find the boy before
the predator and the three attempt to
give the predator its armor back before
a larger more powerful predator emerges
and kills the first the humans flee and
bracket gathers that the predators may
be attempting to improve themselves
through genetic engineering if i'm right
it means they're trying to upgrade
themselves the group is discovered and
interrogated by government agent will
trager and his agent who have taken rory
upon discovering that he gained
knowledge of the aliens mckenna and the
escaped soldiers ambushed tragers agents
before being ambushed by the larger
predator in turn the larger predator
takes rory to his ship seeing his unique
mind as an adaptation worthy of genetic
incorporation and attempts to take off
before mckenna's allies ground the ship
and the yacht jaw is killed with its own
weapons the film ends with the discovery
that the first smaller predator was
transporting a human-sized piece of
advanced predator armor to earth
labelled a predator killer suit
the predator reveals that at some point
the yacht-jaw species began genetic
engineering to incorporate the strengths
of other species into their dna the two
predators we encounter are both
genetically engineered but have wildly
different attributes additionally the
film implicitly folds alien vs predator
into the predator franchise through its
highlighting a weapon exclusive to that
film we also discovered that the human
yachtjaw hybrid was on a mission to
deliver the advanced human-sized
predator killer armor presumably to give
humanity an advantage against a possible
future invasion the reason for this gift
may be due to sympathies resulting from
that specific predator being partially
human but we at least know that the
intentional hybridization of the
yachtjaw species is yet another major
development in the predator mythos
the predator is notable for its
intriguing suggestion that the yacht-jaw
may be interested in the future of
humanity on a larger scale beyond the
hunt including potential genetic
incorporation the film was a relatively
modest success by hollywood standards
delivering a 159 million global box
office on an 88 million dollar budget
critically it wasn't as successful with
a rating of 33 on rotten tomatoes
believe it or not this still makes it
the third highest rated film in the
entire series overall we have yet to see
the full impact of the film's legacy
including the genetic engineering and
the potential for a larger yacht draw
threat but its contribution to their
cinematic mythos is definitely worth
thinking about
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite sci-fi franchises are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]